Yeah, it looks like it's dosing now.
Close to three grams at the moment.
Looks like it's flowing pretty well, too.
And we're getting into the funnel, which is good.
At least from what I can tell.
I'm a little surprised that it stopped.
Unless I didn't load enough in.
I guess I wasn't checking to see if it stopped.
I'll go back to the video.
And go live.
Let's go back until we get to the last.
point at which it was pouring.
OK, so it's going, going, going.
Still see it trickling.
Looks like it's tapping.
OK, and it stopped, even though it was still flowing powder.
What happened?
The new protocol it wrote.
Hey, good.
Yeah.
Bioheap transfer.
I'm not actually totally sure.
Yeah, currently it's the drain.
Also, I'm screen recording my session here.
This is the...
I'm going to stop
for some reason, and I don't know why.
What were you dosing some of the...
Yeah, the atomized.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, sweet.
It was going great, and then it just stopped.
This team is awesome.
Yeah.
Who's lab is this?
This is Chris Dillon's lab.
Dr.
Dillon.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Amazing.
And then I'll be able to bring this over pretty soon, I think.
That's a solid 6063.
Yeah.
Yeah, what you ordered.
Oh.
Is it important for you to do this one?
Nope.
Just clean it with IPA is the only thing.
You can throw both in if you want.
Medium just for
a faster response here.
That's what I get for trying to be fancy.
Bring a demo.
Oh, memory error.
Maybe I should get a Pico 2s.
Save my RAM.
This should be quite solvable.
Since I'm screen recording and I don't have my laptop, then I'm just kind of sitting here.
Kind of okay.
It's a little bit nice, actually.
I'm thirsty.
I'll go with some more.
No, I can't.
Is that on card access?
Hmm.
Never mind.
Something got messed up with my card access.
So if I leave, I can't get back in.
I need to call the engineering lab supervisor.
I will pull up.
I could update.
Okay, it looks like it's backup.
It looks like there's some pieces maybe
kind of stuck in there.
In the nozzle area, some of those larger pieces.
A larger, auger inner channel would help with that, or me just sitting
it with light amount, like I probably should have.
But it's still coming out.
And the views are not, or something else is happening.
That's light.
It looks like we're still getting powder, but yeah, there's really just some bigger pieces in the middle there.
It might
just not be mated properly.
Maybe that back clamp could be helping support
it a little bit better.
I think that put it in exactly though.
Yeah, those bigger chunks really gummed up the nozzle.
That's what Salmon will know about that.
Yeah, I
guess it's not going to be looking out with the clog up there.
Trying to get to 4.5, so it's actually kind of a ways away.
Yeah, it
looks like we're...
Going back again.
Still got that skipping or whatever's going on with the meter.
Even here it's slowing down.
It's getting closer.
Seeing stuff coming out still.
Slaying down even more.
Okay.
Three, two, zero.
Yeah.
Pretty much on spot on.
That's the drift, which was just from the fume hood that we didn't get a perfect seal of the fume hood.
But overall, I'd say that's pretty good.
Probably gonna pop back up in a second.
Update saying it finished, hopefully.
Unless it's just still turning.
There we go.
Posited a, maybe, maybe not a small amount.
That last tilt back.
That tilt back could probably be a lot slower.
Less jarring.
Yeah, just a random other thing.
I noticed the solenoid actually bends a little bit when it hits, just because it's only fixtured on one side.
It's on the 3D print, fixtured to the 3D print, so actually cantilevers just a little bit.
It's kind of interesting.
It's on deflection.
Just hoping it will say it's done any minute.
Maybe I'll just call it there and grab it.
So I've got 8 grams.
Take a small amount.
Load it into the 4047 aluminum.
Load it into the 6063 one end closed tube.
And I gotta go.
So I'm going to...
Okay, we're
finished.
there it is we got balance reading enough time for that last one auger rpm so it kind of came back up a little bit yeah
there we go